unfortunately the media is incorrect in
that them claiming that uh inflation or
high gas prices is because of ukraine uh
the ukraine crisis started you know
maybe the last 60 days
so uh the two years before that
obviously did have an impact um but i do
think that it would be fair to say hey
moving forward a material increase in
gasoline could be attributed to uh this
situation in combination with kind of
russia and saudi arabia and not
increasing production is that kind of
your read on this yeah for start you
absolutely so there's a lot to unpack
financial markets wise um so i'll start
with with gas uh the
the fact that crude oil is up as much as
it is today was up at eight percent this
morning or up eight percent this morning
when i when i checked uh could be up
more or less now but
tells you that there is this sort of
concept about a geopolitical premium
baked into the oil price and it very
clearly is rebutting that today there
was not a geopolitical premium baked
into the oil price otherwise you
wouldn't see of the kind of price action
that we have today
number two
it's very likely to be persistent um to
the extent that we continue to have
geopolitical conflict and as we i said
earlier there's no really no exit ramp
um for this conflict anytime soon
because it strikes me that putin's odds
are directly or putin's goals are
directly at odds with the by
administration um so somebody's going to
have to blink and i'm usually there it
takes a lot more pain for you know for
these major powers to blink
unfortunately um you know one thing i
thought was really interesting to me the
most interesting thing that's happened
in the last 24 hours is the big decline
in the in the real interest rate here in
the us uh this morning is
probably the biggest one-day decline
ever if i have to go back and look
but the 10-year tip shield which is
inflated inflation-adjusted treasury
bondio
declined 25 basis points day every day
that's like a 40 move in terms of the
the percentage change of the move and
it's directly at odds with what happened
yesterday so yesterday we saw bond
yields rise because the sort of specter
of war would tax the sort of the already
depressed productive capacity of the
economy you could actually see more
inflation as a function of this but then
today i think the market is sort of
realizing oh no wait this is actually
bearish because we're going to talk
about 100 oil we're going to 110 oil
gonna earn 20 oil and ultimately the
negative impact that's likely to have on
the us consumer and by extension the
global economy when you start to think
about um
the fed let's go there
your favorite topic yeah well because i
do think that uh whether people like it
or not the fed is ultimately the decider
of what happens to asset prices right
now 100 and you could argue that that's
always been true but i think right now
when you get um uncertainty when you get
chaos when you get uh complexity in the
system yeah and you're looking for
signal a lot of times if you just zero
in on where does the chain of events
start
the fed usually is the uh originator of
a lot of action not all of it but a lot
of it totally
asset prices especially risk assets have
sold off over the last four months or so
because everyone thinks the fed's gonna
raise they're gonna raise the interest
rate they're gonna raise interest rate
as much as i think jp morgan said nine
times uh over the next year obviously i
think that was probably a little strange
they're tripping over themselves the
highest number
who could say 11. you could say 11 and
not get fired you won't write 11. i'll
buy you
like literally that i feel like that's
what's going on here all right so nine i
think people were like all right that's
the extreme uh upside uh but i do think
that if you went and talked to most
people
no raise to 50 basis points in march was
kind of the the aperture of like reality
and i do think that most people would
say 25 basis points to 50 basis points
as a raise in march
48 hours ago i literally think that's
what people thought
i don't know if a lot of people think
that now
in 48 hours with you know literally
the move you know kind of the chess move
of russia saying hey we're gonna go
invade ukraine
does that change or do you still think
that they have to raise in order to
still address the issues here in the
united states oh no the fed's hands are
very much tied in terms of monetary
tightening for a couple of reasons one
you know there has not been a big enough
feedback sort of mechanism in financial
markets in terms of tightening financial
conditions
for the fed to suggest that
somehow they're going to achieve their
inflation mandate or you know sort of or
somehow they need to defend their
maximum and inclusive employment mandate
at this particular juncture we have not
seen enough carnage
credit spreads are you know what 400
basis points over on high yield roughly
thereabouts they could double before you
actually start to see a real big
hit to economic activity as a function
of that um so that's number one and then
number two and this is something that
you know sort of i think that's kind of
the the the second order thinking which
is
if the fed does not raise just given all
the tightening that's been priced into
you know forwards curves then they
effectively amount to easing
which i'm not sure that the central bank
wants to send a signal
that they're easing at this particular
juncture you know what i mean because
it's already priced in so you almost
have to do it right if you don't do it
then the markets will take it out and
that that's how markets will function
and respond to that so
they're already on the path to losing
their credibility if they haven't
already certainly they've lost it with a
large pocket of investors
they might lose it with all of us
if they don't if they don't at least try
to start normalizing monetary policy i'm
going to read you uh a portion of a dm i
got a i reached out to somebody and i
said hey what do you think about this
yesterday it's somebody who has a very
unique kind of intersection they
understand some of the geopolitical
stuff they understand some of the macro
economy stuff they understand bitcoin et
cetera
uh and he sent me back a number of
really intelligent points i don't want
to say who it is because i didn't ask
them uh but one of them um says putin's
making a play on collapsing the dollars
because he can see the massive spread
between cpi and fixed income yields
and driving energy prices higher will
put the ineptitude of the fed and ecb on
full display right to the moment they
were going to pretend to raise rates
and i actually think that like it's a
pretty astute
you know identification of uh
there's other things going on
but one of the impacts or one of the
reasons to take these actions is to
basically just say like
no you're not
you're not we're gonna raise rates like
everything you just said is not gonna
happen yeah is that kind of like what
you're anticipating now like do we get a
interest rate raise in 2022 now like did
we go from nine as the extreme
zero
some poor analyst is gonna get fired for
publishing eleven today
no i know what you mean so let me start
by saying uh whoever wrote that is an
extremely astute investor that's been my
take on this the whole time which is
putin
being the sort of thug that he is
but a very educated smart thug
understands the pain points right across
the global economy paying points in the
global financial system
and why would you not wait
until inflation's at a 40-year high
to invade ukraine and cause trouble in
financial markets because you know
at the bare minimum
the few are going to put the fed in a
conundrum
at the bare maximum you're going to
expose them and cause them to lose their
credibility and so you know this is this
is you know it's sort of like
i i can't even think of a good analogy
but it's it's the it's the former kgb
operative in him that chose to wait
until now
you know just on the eve of the fed's
normalization agenda because again their
credibility is at stake here bullet said
as much a couple weeks ago
obviously the data would suggest that
the credibility's at stake as well so
i think putin is really enjoying himself
right now because quite frankly he's got
the upper hand